for freedom of thought is an honorary
award given by the European Parliament
to individuals or groups who have
dedicated their lives to the defense of
Human Rights and freedom of thought
previous laurates include Nelson Mandela
Malala yusai Dennis mcui and Alexi naali
this year's laurates are Gina mana amini
and the women life Freedom Movement of
Iran who have fought tirelessly for
women's rights in Iran representing them
today and joining me for discussion are
our student
and Mera shafa thank you for joining us
today um perhaps we could start with you
telling us a bit about Gina Marini's
story and what H what sparks the women
life Freedom Movement of
Iran thank you today you gave me the
opportunity to talk about our movement
our movement called women life freedom
and the starting
part
was year three months which it was
started by murdering M and is called but
the movement of woman life freedom is
for all of the women and all of the mar
and the people who have been killed of
in Iran I'm very glad and um thanks for
giving an awarding this big um award the
SAR prize we are years uh fighting for
our rights it is almost 44 years the
Iranian Nation are trying for to get
their freedom and it is almost a year
that we are moving towards um speaking
out loud to the whole world and we find
out this is really a big movement and a
big step this woman life Freedom that
started in Iran and from all of the
Iranian people I'm hoping that good uh
news coming up and um everybody to hear
us uh that it is live and everybody's
hearing us and we are hoping that this
SAR award and prize helps us to reach
our goal and Mission thank you thank you
as um M Ed did you expect such a respon
from women across Iran uh why did you
also decide to to join the
[Music]
protest uh this demonstration that
people industri it was uh not for just
one year we were always against the
current situation in country and
especially for the women right that it
was always under suppression and
discrimination and for that forcefully
and obligatory cover and hijab uh the
Islamic Republic always tried with this
cover and hijab to control over everyone
all of the women and they were
monitoring everybody and they tried to
weaken the
women with the um murdering uh
This was um a stepping stone for us to
go into the streets uh to be next to
each
other and for our the tiny small uh
minor human right that we want to have
it and next to us we're also demand that
they were supporting us um and they
tried to be with us uh aside from that
hijab was a symbol for us and uh it
showed us that um all of us are
disagreeing with Islamic Republic and we
are against that so we not only IND the
streets try to uh be next to each other
we also um gave our words against the
Islamic Republic then we are requesting
that Islamic Republic to go away and uh
we and all of the people try to show
their disagreement and um their issues
uh at any step because uh the government
they radically violate all of the rules
and they killed many people many have
been damaged like me many are in prison
many have been
tortured and unfortunately uh my
people they don't want really to go back
to the former years and they never ever
wants to go back to what happened before
because many people have been killed
many young people many young Generations
from the whole
country and it was not just special for
City everybody were was next to each
other everybody was there and all of
them they had the same goal and Mission
and still we are um demonstrating we are
of course uh the demonstrations and the
opposition and the words are different
like mostly this social um type of uh
disagreement and outside we are trying
to speak loud and to have a role in this
uh movement I see I it sounds really
terrible the conditions you're in and
the adversity you've been facing you
mentioned the hijab van but could you
tell us a bit more about what it's like
to live as a woman in Iran uh what are
the challenges that women face
there there are many challenges uh from
the time we are 7 years old
means like the Islamic religion says
that at 9:
um girl is mature enough um but
unfortunately our girls they go to
school at seven when they are seven
years old and they have to we hijab and
cover and this is really terrible and it
is really hard and especially for women
for do for girls that they have to have
a forceful obligatory hijab and cover
and for example the warmest time in the
summer they have to really tolerate all
of the conditions and here is the gender
discrimination between men and women in
any kind of condition um
because all of um the because the
Islamic Republic fully think um that
without any cover and hijab there would
be a lot of problems the foundations of
the regime will be weakened and uh is
the Islamic religion will be in danger
there is not such a kind of thing and no
idea many women and men they can try
simply live in peaceful coexistence like
other countries but
unfortunately um the Islamic Republic
always forced the people and they try to
really discriminate the situation I see
so it's a lot about control and they're
afraid of people expressing themselves
um you mentioned earlier that of course
there's been a lot of Oppression and
very violent resp response but have
there been any changes I mean what has
broadly been the the development since
the protest began in
Iran if you are thinking after the
movement of women life Freedom there is
no
development uh the problems uh are in
now more than before and especially
after the saharov price it will be even
more than before because the Islamic
Republic from the time that they tried
to make a cage for us and they tried to
ens to the censorship and to censorize
and they try to really make a silent
that nobody speaks a lot speaks loud uh
so they are trying that nobody to be dis
disagreement with that and they are
trying that we follow the all of the
rules and regulations and articles and
it is just for themselves it is just for
what they think in the path that they
think is the best for them so it is
super difficult for the Iranian Nations
and for the people of Iran and we never
ever accept that and we never ever will
agree to that and the Islamic Republic
uh they want that each individual all of
the Iranian people to be under their
control that means that to have them
monitoring and controlling in the way
that they would like to have
relationship in way that they like to
speak in the way they would like in the
way hij they prefer so we cannot even
select our own religious we cannot speak
about politics everything is illegal we
cannot have optional uh cover and
everything is just uh illegal and these
are the smallest
things against the um human crisis that
is happening in Iran and we do not we
are not informed about all the tales
outside so basically this regime is
bringing us to um really destroy the
whole country the whole nation and they
have such a we don't know really what
kind of program and plan do they have
for us but they just want to WIP us our
culture and they want really to destroy
the whole uh Iranian nation and we are
for a long time
trying hard we the Iranian people they
are in a stage that they think that they
have nothing anymore to lose and they
are surely standing that to get their
rights to get rid of discrimination and
they want to uh speak like European and
Western countries to have a normal daily
life uh something that is some like very
usual and normal for us for for us it's
just a wish it's just like a hold and we
are just trying for such a simple uh
goals that it is all of our days weeks
months and years we just want to get our
human rights that I'm
thinking from the prize
afterwards uh necessary that the other
countries really focus on us and help us
absolutely I think it's everyone's right
to live the way they want to live and
given I think it's why your story has
struck a cord around the world but and
given what's happened and getting the
award this week uh what kind of support
do you need I mean what kind of support
are youing looking for whether it's in
IR but also around the
world the supports that we want um I
don't know if I can but I just say it uh
these are
supports from the European
Union and Western countries
because there is no support from outside
from foreign countries we cannot do
anything inside Iran because the
Iranians are like in a c a prison under
the full control of the Islamic Republic
and they are very
limitied and
um we uh have the forces we have the
brain to really do the revolution but we
want the foreign countries to help us
this makes it done and make it
happen so we want that Europe really to
support and to help uh to that our
prisoners not to be executed our um
children not to be
killed like our children and our friends
not to be disabled and uh not to lose
the parts of the organs and the body and
there are many more that I want to say
but uh until today the European
countries and Western countries they
were just uh verbally with us orally uh
from the uh time the early
wom life Freedom we were really happy
when we saw the the news and messages
from European countries and Western
countries that they were sympathizing
with us but after that it is almost one
year and three months we are just
getting angry because we are just uh
hearing messages we need prac we need
practical stuff because that doesn't
help us if you just say something
because there are many students and many
children many teenagers that have been
executed they are raped they are
sexually abused so we really want
Europe not to orally be with us and and
practically to help
us life woman life
Freedom Movement um the during the time
all of the facilities that they could
really sacrifice the people and to kill
people they got it from European
countries Western countries for example
um to really have control monitoring all
of the facilities that they need to
control and all of the technology they
they got it from European Western
countries they got it from Black Market
so everything um that uh they there are
so many of the technology that if you
walk in the street and uh all of the
people the who are working with the
Islamic Republic they have uh fully
armed and they got it all from the
Western countries so um
after
after the the time that the European
Union they were with us next to us which
of course it was not a kind of just
simply an honor but we really need after
this price not to sell weapons to Iran
not to sell
the deadly technical technology to Iran
we really want the court to set it up ad
that these governmental officials to
come and to be scrutinized because they
our life is not for us and they are just
killing and
murdering there are
many we are just trying uh to really
verbalize all of the names we know all
of the prisoners but there are many more
of the people that are prisoners they
have been and they are under torturing
uh they have no medical services and
nobody hear about them because even
their family are under pressure under
full censorship and their families
cannot also really work and really we
want to find out a solution how to help
these families these people that are in
prison and they are political prisoners
and what happened to them are they
killed and be murdered or not see
there's clearly a lot of things that
could be done and hopefully there is
some support um that brings me to my
next point which is where we were here
to relay these messages to European
leaders uh this prize what does it mean
to you receiving it I mean what does it
mean for the movement um in general
uh is this something that you really
looking for is it does it help your
cause or how do you receive
it at least we um did our first step so
after years
um our voice have been heard
we really want that outside uh all of
the human right company institutions
they know
um that the that the other foreign
countries should be with us next to us
like um my sister been killed murdered
um so that we want that the leaders to
be with us next to
us who have lost one or two or two I so
support and be beside
them at least we take a step forward in
the way that we are expecting their
support from because at the moment in
current conditions that we have been
that we have talking to you we are
experiencing such
atrocities understand uh and finally
what is the key message of your movement
uh to people in Iran and around the
world I what do you want them to take
away um
today
[Music]
my message could be that we shouldn't
submit ourselves to
oppression we shouldn't uh stay quiet
and we should continue our efforts and
we always should protest and uh fight
for our
right the movement which we have started
it it has started from an Islamic
country
the women in the country managed to
protest in the government Tred to
oppress
them and they wanted to have distinction
between
men so from the day of our birth we have
been classified divided into two
separate
classes so we want to prove to the world
that we shouldn't keep quiet against
operation they should stand against it
and they
should into streets we didn't expect
that one day we will achieve this
much while I didn't go to the streets in
pursuit of any Prize or achievement but
just for the protection of my rights but
for betterment of the condition
fut
Generations
I I performed as a youngster as a young
Soldier
for in the defense of for our rights
along my sisters with empty
hands against those oppressors who were
equipped but we weren't fear
even when I'm here today I would like to
continue the path I will continue my
effort and
struggle with these efforts I would like
to share the situation of Iran Iranian
people and express it to the
world I can not summarize the atrocities
in the killings uh that is taking place
in Iran in 10 minutes of
interview are many families that have
been suffering
there there are families that have been
mourning for example there are people
that are mourning for my losses and for
others
loses all these gatherings in these
sessions in this uh
prize will become fruitful in the form
of achievement and it shouldn't limit
to words on and enable
us to take at least the step that we
have taken to pursue this process and
take further more steps in this way
thank you m as soon is there anything
you would like to add to that
message
[Music]
I think as Mercedes
said this platform might be very limited
to express all the atrocities that we
have been experienced think in
seeing it is a drip sorry it is a drop
in the
ocean
we have experienced admit such
atrocities in a
country the problems that we have
experienced are much greater to what we
have shared
with have have some hope because they
have been struggling for the past 15
months they have been struggling
and investing their energies just to
raise their voices and to share their
voices but at least the first step has
been
taken and thanks to God that now we
[Music]
have we are witnessing that at least
their voice is being heard even though
if it is a a very preliminary stage but
it is it has
started the Su is going to be us
I know
every we have been putting efforts
together and I
[Music]
believe I would like to say that I am
going to be part of this movement I will
be beside my
[Music]
people I will sh and raise the voice of
my people and I'll become their
voice to the best of my efforts and
abilities and I am hopeful that we will
achieve our goals very
soon okay well thank you uh
unfortunately that's all we have time
for today uh soona I'd like to thank you
for joining us today and sharing your
incredible story with us uh would be a
drop in the ocean it was really eye
opening and fascinating
and terrible and equal measure um but um
if you'd like to find out more
information about the women uh life
Freedom Movement in Iran you can visit
our website or check out what
information our social media channels
thank you for joining us
goodbye